Rob you've been having a tough time with
a certain game the last few days have no
yeah yeah halo 5 no skidding uh rive
rife yeah I've ride the last game from
two tribes developer about a year or two
ago toki Tori yeah too and they
essentially just announced their early
retirement from game development they
said essentially the they call
themselves dinosaurs in the blog and
they said that there's just too many
things to keep up with if they've been
developing game since 2000 and they
can't really keep up with twitch and
just like this explosion of any games
that like there's markets flooded or
this is what they were yeah paraphrasing
well I guess I'm like making this
gesture I talked to them back during GDC
and they actually wanted to make it very
clear this isn't like a we can't keep up
kind of thing like that's not the basis
of it what's really driving their new
direction to back out is they told me
that they kind of accomplished what they
set out to do like they've figured out
okay these are the games we want to make
we figured out how to make them an drive
is sort of like their game the thing
they've been working towards this whole
time both like develop the skills and
development in business and and all of
that so yeah I think it's partially like
that but I think it's got more to do
with like those aren't the challenges
they set out to accomplish developing
cool games is what they set out to
accomplish and they feel like they've
done it at this point cool why that's I
guess that's admirable I think a lot of
developers probably yeah I'm not
developer but I you hear like horror
stories about crunch and development and
like how a lot of people just like
getting that cycle and don't know how to
get out of that hamster wheel I guess so
that's good on them for doing that now
rive is out today out today you've been
playing a rob you said has been pretty
tough I meet audited I go back and forth
with with how I feel about the
difficulty like on one hand I think it's
a hard-ass game and the other the game
actually makes me feel this way I'll get
into that but I feel like I'm a loser
and I suck at video games okay cuz just
to explain that further is this game is
crazy i'm not this is not my type of
style of game necessarily kinda like
that contra fast-moving always be
shooting so their moments were like I
had to learn okay you can't just you
can't stay still you got to always move
um
but this game will beat you up like add
our souls game like are you just at you
will enter a room and it's just like
Olaf is coming out what you gonna do you
got half a second figure it out you're
constantly dying and every time you die
there's a new message that pops up and
it says stuff like wrecked with the K
like you suck literally like you suck
makes it personal it makes I felt like I
had a roller coaster over time first I
was like this is way too hard and then
when it was those messages actually I
became a fan of because they love right
yeah like dude it's just it's beating
you down and the only thing you can do
is climb out of it or you quit the game
and you walk away like a coward so
they're like my best moments or favorite
moments in this game where when i'm
talking like 12 deaths 20 deaths cannot
get past this one part there was even a
message and i don't know if this is
because the build we had was a little
interesting i'm pretty sure this is was
in the game but a menu came up and it's
like oh like you wanted to turn down to
difficulty to like fuzzy wuzzy mode or
some like that and it wouldn't let me
click it I had a quick completely hard
and keep going uh and then it was
baiting you too late it's so it's a week
it's it's kind of fun in that respect so
yeah again like eventually I was
legitimately mad and kicked ass on that
fume uh and was able to get out of those
situations at many of times I just felt
like a real intentional part of the game
yeah it's fun it's fun to move around
now I having played a few hours last
night I wasn't it wasn't dying so
constantly that the gummy um burnout but
it was more or less kind of like what
was happening in the later half of the
game we're like you know it's like
mission 6 or 5 and it's like oh they're
throwing you into the same map but now
it's zero g look yeah just artificially
inflating it yeah and just also clarify
for people who don't about the game
there's like three kind of more or less
what's nice is they keep turning off and
on mechanics of the game but generally
it's like you have your asteroid esque
side-scrolling type of game and then
it's like a walk around kind of you know
go through corridors and stuff and then
it's like an underwater zero-g type
stuff
anyway stay so they throw those in back
and forth it's like man when I'm
repeating the same map or level design
but now it's in zero-g I'm not getting
much out of that uh that plus the the
character of the game Peter we saw this
actually at PAX East a few years ago and
this did not have this narrative
character I mean the day I was like a
compact Demma they had but yeah I mean
what you described to me is something
that's kind of new to me yeah it's just
this character who I couldn't remember
his name so I tried looking up and
protagonist yes he's actually the
character inside your bot you're like
thing that you control okay and his name
is like literally it's like snake pilot
like he doesn't even have like an actual
name anyways he's like it Stallone guy
that's always like talking and
everything it basically giving us the
story beats however he's for me I just
not a big fan of it when a game is like
making fun of like the video game
industry and it's like Oh Ben there's
one I was like oh man these first person
shooter guys don't have this perspective
like this is way cooler all right what's
wrong with that or uh oh look it's like
an asteroids game it's like this game is
cool and visually appealing to me I
rather have no story and just kind of
immerse myself and there's also a like a
side antagonist robot that's kind of
learning you around it'd be cool just to
have that he could just lure you around
that's fine that's all I need I want to
feel like a little like I want to have
questions but this guy is just he's
constantly talking and it's something I
wish I could just literally turn off and
that was just kind of overwhelming and
and skin me annoyed with the game toward
the end or I didn't beat it by like
towards my last play to go back to a
gameplay for a second does the
difficulty ramp up or you pretty much
just thrown into the fire right away
your your fire pretty quick you start
off yet again I should mention that so
you have your main gun right here which
is always on that's like your sole means
of like survival and as the game
progressed you get unlocks you get armor
upgrades via bolts that are gathered
from enemies and so you get different
types of weapons shotgun missiles and
stuff like that get to hack robots as
well but like hell yeah yeah yeahs hack
like health robots or even turret robots
to like aid you so
your question again I was curious if the
difficulty you said the difficulty like
throws you into the fire right away I'm
asking because I played a prep PAX Prime
last year and I think it was an earlier
mission but I've stone Pete I looked up
a gameplay video cuz i didn't think i'd
play dr yet i was like oh my god i have
played this game and there's a pet it
was I think packs did a might have been
like the Xbox indie program for the name
of its escaping me right now but uh it
was ID at Xbox thank you myself but um
it was it didn't seem that hard i was
playing an earlier mission and i think
it was just a lot slower pace than what
I've seen here and you were describing
to me is like a contra bullet-hell
platformer so I'm sure they were going
for difficulty the whole time maybe I
just didn't play enough it to get that
sense because looking at these gameplay
doesn't clearly looks very frantic and
difficult it is so let me paint a
picture there are some moments in this
game where they cleverly introduce
elements that affect your mobility so
the mobility factor is huge because you
get these an onslaught of drones who are
just trying to run you out of the
[ __ ] world they're just waves console
waves and you have to keep avoiding and
keep shooting as you are trying to avoid
them but then a monster will muster a
robot will show up and he'll just be
dropping crates randomly now there are
stacks and crates that have to jump over
that keep cat that keep basically
changing the the level formation that
like I had a hard time jumping over
these crates and then more more robots
comes Zoe like it definitely builds and
builds and that particular level with
the lava yeah like those running lava
balls keep happening it you know toward
the end of like his health is the boss's
health is like toward the end like those
things will just keep coming faster
faster so yes it like I know what you
play but like each moment especially
especially boss fights definitely pick
up and that's where I typically dies
right in the end of that stretch um I
feel like that's very much like a dark
souls thing to write legging of the guy
will just start throwing you hold
mutators for waiting for dark souls
esque yeah oh wait i mean i was actually
played I was gonna say it never played
really any dark souls but like hearing
you guys talk about it and like the
feelings and seeing it you know on
screams and stuff it remind me of that
and the frustration factor and you will
die in this game a lot all right
interesting I'm always down for a
difficult game kind of
not having my fill of those lately so
for it maybe record that got kind of
difficult when I was playing we'll talk
about that soon but anyway yeah that's
right it's out now on ps4 and PC and
yeah so that's a last game from two
tribes developers that's their swan song